I'm so excited bikinis kayla's pals and  plenty of PDA Taylor Swift and Tom  Hiddleston continue to show off their  hot new romance during Taylor's annual  fourth of July party her Rhode Island  home source tells ET Tom let Taylor down  to the beach and a pair was making out  in the water acting like no one was  watching Plus look closely at Toms tank  top it says i love TS expect the parents  Blake Lively and Ryan Reynolds also join  the festivities our source says Ryan  seemed really protective over his  pregnant wife even helping her walk over  some rocks to get down to the beach it's  cool to be around your friends and to be  surrounded by them every year Taylor's  party brings out lots of famous faces  this year's squad also includes  supermodel Gigi Hadid and karlie kloss  and orange is the new black stars Uzo  aduba and Ruby Rose last year's brought  out ed Sheeran and Taylor's then  boyfriend Calvin Harris